so I'm embarrassed that I have a career
I talk about things like trust and
cooperation and there should be no
demand for my work but the fact of the
matter is is there is demand for my work
which means that there's an opportunity
it means that trust and cooperation are
not yet standard in our organizations
and yet they should be and we know that
which is why we're looking for ways to
bring those things to our organizations
so I thought I would do something a
little different today you know when
you're speaking to tens of thousands of
people and you have the opportunity to
share a message of course most rational
people would say let's go with something
I've talked about lots of times and I'm
really good at but I'm not normal so I'm
gonna do something completely new and I
hope this works out there are two things
that I think that great leaders need to
have empathy and perspective and I think
these things are very often forgotten
leaders are so often so concerned about
their status of their position in
organization they actually forget their
real job and the real job of a leader is
not about being in charge it's about
taking care of those in our charge and I
don't think people realize this and I
don't think people train for this when
we're junior our only responsibility is
to be good at our jobs that's all we
really have to do and some people
actually go get advanced education and
so that they can be really good at their
jobs accountants or whatever right and
you show up and you work hard and the
company will give us tons and tons of
training how to do our jobs they'll show
us how to use the software they'll send
us away for a few days to get trained in
whatever it is that we're doing for the
company and then they expect us to go be
good at our jobs and that's what we do
we work very hard and if you're good at
your job they'll promote you and at some
point you'll get promoted to position
where we're now responsible for the
people who do the job we used to do but
nobody shows us how to do that and
that's why we get managers and not
leaders because the reason our managers
micromanaging us is because they
actually do know how to do the job
better than us that's what got them
promoted really what we have to do is go
through a transition some people make it
quickly some people make it slowly and
unfortunately some people will never
make that transition at all which is we
have to go this through this transition
of being responsible for the job and
then turning it to somebody who's now
responsible for the people who are
responsible for the job and as I said
before one of the great things that is
lacking in most of our companies is that
they are not teaching us how to lead and
leadership is a skill like any other is
a practice' balloon able skill and it is
something that you work on it's like a
muscle if you practice it all the days
you will get good at it and you will get
become a strong leader if you stop
practicing you will become a weak leader
like parenting everyone has the capacity
to be a parent doesn't mean everybody
wants to be a parent and doesn't mean
everybody shouldn't be a parent
leadership is the same we all have the
capacity to be a leader doesn't mean
everybody should be a leader and it
doesn't mean everybody wants to be a
leader and the reason is because it
comes at great personal sacrifice
remember you're not in charge you're
responsible for those in your charge
that means things like when everything
goes right you have to give away all the
credit and when everything goes wrong
you have to take all the responsibility
that sucks right it's things like
staying late to show somebody what to do
it's things like when something does
actually break when something goes wrong
instead of yelling and screaming and
taking over you say try again when the
overwhelming pressures are not on them
the overwhelming pressures are on us at
the end of the day great leaders are not
responsible for the job they're
responsible for the people who are
responsible for the job they're not even
responsible for the results I love
talking to CEOs and say what's your
priority and they put their hands on
their hips all proud and say my priority
is my customer I'm like really you even
talk to a customer in 15 years
there's no CEO on the planet responsible
for the customer they're just not
they're responsible for the people who
responsible for the people who
responsible for the customer I'll tell
you a true story a few months ago I
stayed at the Four Seasons in Las Vegas
it is a wonderful hotel and the reason
it's a wonderful hotel is not because of
the fancy beds any hotel can go and buy
a fancy bed
the reason it's a wonderful hotel is
because of the people who work there
if you walk past somebody at the Four
Seasons and this and they say hello to
you you get the feeling that they
actually wanted to say hello to you it's
not that somebody told them that you
have to say hello to all the customers
say hello to all the guests right you
actually feel that they care now in
their Lobby they have a coffee stand and
I one afternoon I went to buy a cup of
coffee and there was a barista by the
name of Noah who was serving me Noah was
fantastic he was friendly and fun and he
was engaging with me and I had so much
fun buying a cup of coffee I actually
think I gave 100 percent tip right he
was wonderful so as is my nature I asked
Noah do you like your job and without
skipping a beat Noah says I love my job
and so I followed up I said what is it
that the four seasons is doing that
would make you say to me I love my job
and without skipping a beat Noah said
throughout the day managers will walk
past me and ask me how I'm doing if
there's anything that I need to do my
job better
he said not just my manager any manager
and then he said something magical he
says I also work at Caesars Palace and
Caesars at Caesar's Palace the managers
are trying to make sure we're doing
everything right they catch us when we
do things wrong he says when I go to
work there I like to keep my head under
the radar and just get through the day
so I can get my paycheck he says here at
the Four Seasons I feel I can be myself
same person entirely different
experience from the from the customer
who will engage with Noah so we in
leadership are always criticizing the
people we're always saying we've got to
get the right people on
buzz I've got to fill my wrong my team I
gotta get the right people but the
reality is it's not the people it's the
leadership if we create the right
environment we will get people like Noah
at the four seasons if we create the
wrong environment we will get people
like Noah at Caesar's Palace it's not
the people and yet we're so quick to
hire and fire you can't hire and fire
your children if there's if your kids
are struggling we don't say you got to
see at school you're up for adoption so
why is it that when somebody has
performance problems at work why is it
that our instinct is to say you're out
we do not practice empathy
what does empathy look like here's the
lack of empathy this is normal in our
business world you walk into someone's
office someone walks into our office and
says your numbers have been down for the
third quarter in a row you have to pick
up your numbers otherwise I can't
guarantee what the future will look like
how inspired you think that person is to
come to work the next day here's what
empathy looks like you walk into
someone's office someone walks into your
office and says your numbers are down
for the third quarter in a row are you
okay I'm worried about you what's going
on
we all have performance issues maybe
someone's kid is sick maybe they're
having problems in their marriage maybe
one of their parents is dying we don't
know what's going on in their lives and
of course it will affect performance at
work empathy is being concerned about
the human being not just their output
and we have to practice empathy and one
of the groups that we are pretty bad at
practicing empathy with is our young
Millennials so let me show you what
empathy looks like listening to
understand trying to understand
someone's point of view and disposition
and a hundred percent of the talks that
I give her the meetings that I have
invariably someone will raise their hand
and ask about the Millennial problem
apparently this young generation is
unbeatable apparently they have
confounded every single company in every
single industry and so now it's at the
point where companies have given up and
are now just asked
Millennials what do you want and so they
say we want free food and bean bags and
so now every company has free food and
bean bags and guess what nothing has
changed so what I thought we would do
what I thought I would do is show you
what empathy looks like how do we
practice empathy with someone we don't
understand how do we practice empathy
with an organization or a group that
we're struggling with right so we have
to understand that it breaks down to
four things I've broken it down into
parenting technology impatience and
environment let's talk about parenting
first too many Millennials have grown up
subject to what has been described as a
failed parenting strategy too many of
them were told as they were growing up
that they were special that they can
have whatever they want just because
they want it they got medals for coming
in last they got participation medals
right and the science and this is
already good we know that it devalues
the feeling that somebody who works hard
and comes in first place and it actually
makes the person who comes in last
embarrassed because they know they don't
deserve it so it actually makes them
feel worse it actually doesn't help
there are a lot of kids who got into
honors classes not because they deserved
it but because their parents complained
and they got A's nothing because they
earned them but because the teachers
didn't want to deal with the parents
right then those kids graduate no Goodis
and they start a job and in an instant
they find out that they're not special
that you don't get anything just because
you want it you get nothing for coming
in last
and your parents cannot help you get a
promotion and in an instant their entire
self-image is completely shattered in an
instance the way they view themselves
has completely changed turned on its
head
and so what you find is that there's an
entire generation growing up with lower
self-esteem than previous generations
remember they have grown up in an
Instagram Facebook snapchat world in
which they are very very good at putting
filters on everything they're very very
good at
curating how they want to be seen and we
think they're full of confidence they
seem to have all the answers they seem
to be telling us what to do at the end
of the day it's just not there it's just
not true it's just not true their
confidence is a lot weaker than before
they don't know where they're coming
from they don't know where they're going
they're unsure of themselves and they
lack the courage to ask we say things
like my door is always open
assume assuming that they have the
courage to walk through the door number
one then we add in technology there's a
chemical in our body called dopamine
dopamine is responsible for the feelings
we get when we find something we're
looking for or we accomplish something
we set out to accomplish you know that
great feeling you get when you cross
something off your to-do list when you
win the game
when you hit the target right when the
client get the promotion whatever it is
that elation find your keys that elation
comes from a chemical in our body called
dopamine right now other substances
other things that release dopamine
include alcohol nicotine gambling they
go that's what makes us feel good when
we engage with those things and it's the
root of a lot of addiction in fact
almost every alcoholic on the planet
discovered alcohol when they were
teenagers
you see when we're very very young the
only approval we need is approval from
our parents and then as we go through
adolescence we now crave the approval of
our peers very frustrating for our
parents very important for us it allows
us to acculturate outside of our
immediate families into the larger tribe
very very important right it's a time of
high stress and high anxiety and we're
supposed to learn to rely on our friends
some people quite by accident discover
alcohol and the numbing effects of
dopamine to help them cope with the
stress and that becomes hardwired and
then for the rest of their lives when
they suffer some kind of extreme stress
they don't turn to a person they turn to
the bottle right now we also know that
dopamine is released with cell phones
and social media so that Bing bass but
flashing beep that we get from our
phones that feels so good it releases
dopamine we like getting it yes we all
hate all the emails but we love the Bing
right we've all been in this position
you know you're feeling a little bit
down you're feeling a little bit sorry
maybe feeling a little bit sad so what
do we do we send out ten texts to ten
friends hi hi hi hi hi and we hope that
they write back because it feels good
right so now we have a young generation
with basically unfettered access to
social media and cell phones we have age
restrictions on alcohol we have age
restrictions on smoking and we have age
restrictions on gambling
we have no age restrictions on this
other dopamine producing device called
social media or cell phones it's the
equivalent of throwing open the liquor
cabinet and telling our young
adolescents I know this is a stressful
time try the vodka it'll get you through
these hard times that's basically what
we're doing and so what's happening is
huh it's becoming hardwired where our
young generation isn't learning the
coping skills and coping mechanisms to
turn to another human being when they're
struggling or stressed they're turning
to social media or their cell phones
their self-worth sometimes becomes
wrapped up and how many likes they get
they obsessively check how many likes
somebody likes how many likes and
actually will get depressed if they
don't get any you see them going out
with their friends and instead of
connecting with their friends they will
simply sit and talk on the phone let me
show you something that's really
powerful can I borrow your phone please
there's one right there in between you
just let me borrow that for a sec I'm
asking you to give me somebody else's
phone you don't have to turn it on I
just need it thank you so let me show
you the subconscious power of this
device what if I were to hold my phone
while I'm giving this presentation I'm
not checking it it's not buzzing it's
not beeping I'm simply holding it do you
feel like you're the most important
thing to me right now no you do not and
this is an artificial environment now
think about how often this phone is out
while we're talking to other people hey
boss can I talk to you sure what's on
your mind as opposed to sure what's on
your mind
we go out for dinner or lunch with our
family and our friends we have meetings
and we put the phone on the table which
sends a subconscious message to
everybody else in the room that this is
not that important to me you're not that
important to me and by the way putting
your phone upside down is not more
polite this is this is my favorite one
where the phone rings in the middle of
dinner in the middle of a lunch in the
middle of a meeting and somebody goes
I'm not gonna answer it
oh my god is so magnanimous right thank
you
right put it away keep it away because
what it does is it actually hurts our
ability to relate to each other now you
look at young kids these days they're on
them all the time I don't blame them it
is addiction we yell and scream at them
but we like yelling and screaming and an
alcoholic it doesn't help the fact that
it's a chemical addiction right so you
take an insecure generation that now
through no fault of their own struggles
to cope with stress they don't know how
to cope with and deal with stress and as
they have told me many of them will
admit that they struggle to form deep
meaningful relationships they will admit
that many of their friendships are
superficial right that their friends
they know would cancel on them if they
get a better plan that they wouldn't
really know who to talk to if they get
depressed and maybe they'll turn to an
online support group which is not a real
thing it's not human right and we've
seen the impact of this we're starting
to see rises of depression in this
generation we're starting to see rise of
suicide in this generation we're
starting to see a rise of accidental
death due to drug overdose from this
generation universities are currently
dealing with an epidemic that they've
never dealt with before which is the
number of kids requesting leaves of
absence due to depression right now
those are all extreme examples the less
extreme and more likely example is that
someone will go through life just never
really finding joy or fulfillment and
everything's just fine how's your job
that's fine how are your friends you
know there
fine but no joint because you just
cannot because joy fulfillment comes
from this it comes from human
interaction we are social animals and we
need it and we have to learn to rely on
our friends and that skill is
desperately lacking so you add in the
next one impatience this generation is
often accused of being entitled and if
you've worked with any of them before
sure seems that way
but I would argue that we're miss
reading the tea leaves they're not
entitled they're impatient again let's
practice empathy how did they grow up
they grew up in a world of instant
gratification you want to buy something
you go in Amazon it shows up the next
day you want to watch a movie you don't
check movie times you just log on and
download it whenever you want to watch
it stream it right you want to watch a
TV show you don't wait week to week to
week just finish watch for the weekend
in fact if you want to get hold of
somebody you don't leave a message on
their machine and wait for hours for
them to get the message and call you
back you just text them and they'll call
you they'll get back to literally
instantaneously heck if you want to go
on a date you don't even have to be like
hey you just swipe right you got a date
never learn the skill set of like what
are you doing right you can have four
dates in the night in other words
everything comes instantaneously they
have falsely applied the instant
gratification model to life fulfillment
and career fulfillment they wanted all
instantaneously
the problem is life relationships career
are not destinations like look I found
the job I love that's not how it works
it's not it's not a scavenger hunt I'm
looking for the job that will no it
doesn't work that way it's a journey
it's a it's a cut like it's the same
with love it's like I found love no you
did you work hard every single day to
stay in love it's a journey
it's as if they're standing at the foot
of a mountain they know exactly what
they want they can see the summit what
they don't see is the mountain I talked
to some recent college grads who are in
their their entry-level jobs on a
regular basis and I'll ask them things
like how's it going and they'll say
yeah I think I'm gonna quit I'm like why
they're like I'm not making an impact
I'm like you know you've been here eight
months right and this is the problem
they see it as destination I'm not
making an impact I hear it all the time
but they don't even know what that means
impact yes we all want to make an impact
what kind of impact what you want to do
when how do you want to contribute to
the world is what vision is this is what
Y is it's become generic and abstract
but the problem is is they're wafting
around they're looking for the the right
they'll go from job to job to job hoping
that the next one sticks they go from
relationship to relationship hoping that
the next one is the love what that I've
been looking for they don't know how to
ask for help and their makes them feel
even worse because they can't find the
thing that they're looking for maybe
it's me so if an insecure generation
that doesn't have coping mechanisms that
wants everything resolved and resolved
now I haven't thought let me just send a
text as opposed to let me wait an hour
when I'm done with lunch with you and
then I'll send my text for example and
then we get to the fourth and most
egregious of the four observations
environment we're now taking this
wonderful smart idealistic ambitious
hard-working good group of people that
were dealt a bad hand and we're putting
them in corporate environments that do
not care about them as human beings
right we have for some reason our work
world has changed in the past twenty and
thirty years we are suffering the side
effect of business theories left over
from the 80s and 90s and they are bad
for people and they are bad for business
let me give you an example the concept
of shareholder supremacy was a theory
proposed in the late 1970s and it was
popularized in the 80s and 90s it is now
standard form today you talk to any
public company and you ask them their
priority and they say maximize
shareholder value really that's like a
coach prioritizing the needs of the fans
over the needs of the players how you
going to build a winning team with that
model but that's normal today we
even perceive it as broken or damaged or
wrong or outdated remember the 80s and
90s were boom years with relative peace
and a kinder gentler cold war nobody was
practicing hiding under their desks in
school anymore we are no longer in those
times these are no longer boom years
these are no longer peaceful times and
those models cannot work today here's
another one mass layoffs using someone's
livelihood to balance the books right
it's so normal in America today that we
don't even understand how broken and how
damaging it is not only to human beings
but to business you know companies talk
about how they want to build trust in
cooperation then they announce a round
of layoffs do you know the quickest way
to destroy trust and destroy cooperation
in a business literally in one day lay
people off and everyone gets scared
right can you imagine sending someone
home to say honey I can no longer
provide for our family because the
company missed its arbitrary projections
this year and forget about the people
who lost their job think about the
people who kept their jobs because every
single decision a company makes as a
piece of communication and the company
cut the company has just communicated to
everybody else this is not a meritocracy
we don't care how hard you work or how
long you've worked here if we miss our
numbers and you happen to fall on the
wrong side of the spreadsheet I'm sorry
we cannot guarantee employment in other
words we come to work every day afraid
and we're asking our youngest generation
to work in environments where how would
any of us ever stand up and admit I made
a mistake we're constantly being told
you have to be vulnerable leaders are
vulnerable what does that even mean it
doesn't mean you walk around crying I'm
vulnerable right know what vulnerability
means is you create an environment in
which someone feels safe enough to raise
their hand and said I don't know what
I'm doing
you've given me a job and I haven't been
trained to do it I need help I made a
mistake I screwed something up I'm
scared
I'm worried all of these things no one
would
ever admit inside a company because it
puts a target on your head in case
there's another round and so we keep it
to ourselves and how can a company ever
do well if nobody's ever willing to
admit they made a mistake that's scared
or they don't know what they're doing
and so we've literally created cultures
in which every single day everybody
comes to work and light hide lies hides
and fakes and we're asking our youngest
generation to work and succeed and find
themselves and build their confidence
and overcome their addiction to
technology and build strong
relationships at work we're asking to do
this and these lis environments we've
created we keep saying to them you're
the future leaders we're the leaders now
we're in control what are we doing this
is what empathy means it means if
there's an entire generation struggling
maybe it's not them it's like you know
the only thing that I that the common
factor in all my failed relationships me
same thing well we just can't get the
right act or you know the right
performance out of our people maybe it's
you right it's not a generation it's not
them they're not difficult or hard to
understand they're human beings like the
rest of us trying to find their way
trying to work in a place where they
feel that someone cares about them as a
human being by the way that's what we
all want in other words it's not even
generational it's all of us this is the
practice of empathy that if we're
struggling to communicate to someone it
was struggling to help someone be at
their natural best I'm tired of people
saying to me how do I get the best out
of my people really that's what you want
they're like a towel just wring them how
can I get the most out of them know how
do I help my people be at their natural
best right we're not asking these
questions we are not practicing empathy
we have to start by practicing empathy
and relate to what they may be going
through and it will profoundly change
the decisions we make it will profoundly
change the way we see the world
someone's driving to work you're driving
to work and someone wants to cut into
your lane what
do you pull your car up would you let
them in most of us pull our cars up and
go like this you wait your turn
now let's practice empathy I don't know
maybe they've been out of work for six
months maybe they had trouble getting
the kids out to school this morning and
now they're running late for a really
important interview and they just have
to get to this interview and they're
gonna cut into our lane or maybe they're
just a bastard I don't know but that's
the point we don't know we don't know
and the practice of empathy will say
I'll let them in and I'll arrive to work
one car lengths late right we don't
always have to be right
we'd always have to be in charge we
don't have to be the one who succeeds
it's not about winning or losing and
that's where I go to the second point
after empathy comes perspective where
it's not about winning or losing
in game theory there are two kinds of
games there are finite games and there
are infinite games and this is how
you're going to change your perspective
right a finite game is defined as known
players fixed rules and an agreed upon
objective baseball for example we know
the rules we all agree to the rules and
whoever has more runs at the end of nine
innings is the winner and the game is
over no one ever says if we can just
play two more innings I know we can come
back doesn't work that way the game is
over right that's a finite game then you
have an infinite game infinite games are
defined as known and unknown players the
rules are changeable and the objective
is to keep the game in play to
perpetuate the game when you pit a
finite player versus a finite player the
system is stable baseball is stable
right when you pit an infant an infinite
player versus an infinite player this
system is also stable like the Cold War
for example because there cannot be a
winner and a loser there are no winners
and losers in an infinite game right it
doesn't exist because there are no
winners or losers what ends up happening
the infinite contest is players drop out
when they run out of the will or the
resources to play but there's no winners
or losers problems arise when you pit a
finite player versus an infinite player
because if a finite player is playing to
win and an infinite player is to playing
to keep the game going right this is
what happened to us in Vietnam we were
playing to win and the Vietnamese were
fighting for their lives we were the
ones who got stuck in quagmire this is
the Soviet Union in Afghanistan they
were trying to beat the Mujahideen and
the Mujahideen would fight for as long
as is necessary quagmire now let's look
at business the game of business has
pre-existed or has existed long before
every single company that exists on this
planet today and it will outlast every
single company that it lives that exist
on this planet today there's no winning
the game of business and the reason is
is because we haven't agreed to the
rules I get such a kick out of this you
realize how many companies actually
don't know the game they're in right
listen to the language of the companies
use we're trying to beat our competition
we're trying to be number one did you
know that we were ranked number one look
at the listing based on what criteria
revenues profits market share square
footage number of employees based on
what time frame a quarter a year five
years ten years 20 years 50 years 100
years I haven't agreed to those
standards how can you declare yourself
the winner
how can you declare yourself number one
where no one else in the game has agreed
to the rules it's arbitrary there is no
winning because there's no end in other
words companies are playing finite games
listen to their language they're trying
to beat their competition what does that
even mean it's the leaders and the
companies that understand the game that
they're in and organize their resources
and their decision-making around the
infinite contest that outlast and
frustrate their competition all the
companies that we've referred to as the
exceptions Southwest Airlines Apple
computers harley-davidson they're the
exception no they're playing the
infinite contest they frustrate their
competition is what happens that's what
happens because they
playing to win Jim Senegal the founder
of Costco which is the company only real
company that gives Walmart a run for its
money
he says public companies are looking to
succeed for the quarter says we're
looking for the next 50 years you can
hear him
he's playing the infinite contest I
spoke at a Leadership Summit for
Microsoft I also spoke at a Leadership
Summit for Apple now at the Microsoft
summit I would say 70% of the executives
and this was under the Steve Ballmer
days I would say about 70% of the
executives spend about 70% of their
presentations talking about how to beat
Apple at the Apple Summit a hundred
percent of the executives spent a
hundred percent of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach
and how to help students learn one was
obsessed with their competition the
other one was obsessed with where
they're going so at the end of my
presentation at Microsoft they gave me a
gift they gave me the new Zune which was
the competitor to the iPod touch when it
was a thing right and I have to tell you
this piece of technology was spectacular
it was beautiful the user interface was
incredible the design was amazing it was
intuitive it was one of the most
beautiful elegant pieces of technology
I'd ever seen
right now they didn't work with iTunes
which is an entirely different problem I
couldn't use it
but that's something else I'm sitting in
the back of a taxi with a senior Apple
executive sort of employee number twelve
kind of guy and I decide to stir the pot
and I turned him I say you know I spoke
at a Microsoft summit and they gave me
their new Zune and I have to tell you it
is so much better than your iPod touch
and he turned to me and said I have no
doubt conversation over because the
infinite player isn't playing to be
number one every day with every product
they're playing to outlast the
competition if I had said to Microsoft
oh I've got the new iPod touch it's so
much better than your new Zune there was
a can we see it what does it do how we
have to see it because one is obsessed
with their competition the other is
obsessed with why they do what they do
the other is obsessed with where they're
going and the reason Apple frustrates
their competition is because secretly
they're not even competing against them
they're competing against themselves and
they understand that sometimes you're a
little bit ahead and sometimes you're a
little bit behind and sometimes your
product is better and sometimes you're
not but if you wake up every single
morning and compete against yourself how
do I make our products better than they
were yesterday how do I take care of our
customers better than we did yesterday
how do we advance our cause more
efficiently more productively than we
did yesterday how do we find new
solutions to advance our calling our
cause our purpose our belief are why
every single day what you'll find is
over time you will probably be ahead
more often those who play the infinite
game understand it's not about the
battle it's about the war and they don't
play to win every day and they frustrate
their competition until their
competition drops out of the game every
single bankruptcy almost every merger
and acquisition is basically a company
saying we no longer have the will or the
resources to continue to play and we
have no choice to either drop out of the
game or
or merge our resources with another
player so that we can stay in the game
that's what that is and you can think
about the number of bankruptcies and
mergers and acquisitions it's kind of
proof that most companies don't even
know the game they're in you want to be
a great leader start with empathy you
want to be a great leader change your
perspective and play the game you're
actually playing thank you very much